hi there steve kaufman here today i'm
going to talk about the rules of grammar
how we learn them
my views on learning grammar
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe
also since there was an election in
france today and the centrist
uh candidate
emmanuel macron won i'm going to follow
this with a
summary of the same
basic content in french for those of you
who are learning french grammar rules of
grammar how do we learn them my view you
know i refer back to the there's a
famous
sufi sufi is a philosoph a branch of
islam i don't know that much about it
but there is a saying that says you can
only learn what you already know
now what i find with grammar because
i've exposed myself now to i don't know
how many hundreds of hours of greek
i am now
starting
to look at a grammar book because
as i look at this grammar book
i see a bunch of explanations
that refer to things that i have already
experienced and to some extent already
know although some things i don't quite
notice while i'm listening and so
this grammar review helps me to
realize just how
uh the language is working to notice how
it's working but
this would only make sense to me if i've
already had this massive exposure to
grammar and that is always my approach
and i recommend
this series essential grammar which
exists for italian for french
and for many other languages put out by
dover you can google for it because what
you want in a grammar book by the way
where they didn't find them i bought
this book here when i was in prague
uh tech grammar and what you want in a
grammar book is you want it to be
small
as small as possible because you're
going to have to go there over and over
again flip through it
again look at things that you
read understood forgot go back in again
as you gain more experience with the
language more and more of these rules
refer to things that you have
experienced that you understand it helps
you understand notice things when you're
watching
um
and so a grammar book should have no in
my opinion of course should have no
exercises forget the exercises too many
language books mix everything up you've
got some learning content some grammar
explanations some grammar examples and
some
exercises all you want in my opinion is
a an essence of the grammar with enough
examples so that you can sense what
they're talking about and ideally you go
to the grammar book
after you've had i mean you can have an
initial review of the grammar because
you won't really it won't make much
sense to you they'll talk about things
that are going to happen in the language
that you haven't experienced it so it
has very little impact but then you go
back again and again
and that is why
contrary to many language earnest
learners i'm not a great fan of asimil
although i have bought
emil books in the past and i used the
russian one i found the korean one too
boring and i have not really yet delved
into these because i'm not sorry because
i'm not that motivated to
because what assimil does is it mixes up
content and in the case of russian they
had very good content but without enough
repetition
which is what we have in our mini
stories where within each story
the vocabulary repeats and the patterns
repeat
and then of course many of these within
a series of stories 5 10 15 20 stories
we focus in on a particular range of
patterns uh in our many stories uh at
least for the first 50 stories we're
focusing in on high frequency verbs
because the verbs are key in my opinion
so we get more repetition in so far as
content is concerned but in assimil they
mix in content
with translation
with exercises with grammar explanations
and i think things should be separate
grammar
rules with examples here content over
there and the content should be a very
high degree of repetition and on that
basis eventually you get to understand
the grammar now i wanted to point out i
went and picked up somewhere and where
is it now oh maybe i don't have it here
an english grammar oh here it is
you know and and i found a small one
because i was looking for small grammar
books
what happens is the more you have heard
the language the more you're familiar
with the language
when you read the grammar the more it
seems that they are describing things
that are
obvious and therefore it becomes harder
and harder to read the grammar
explanations because it seems that
they're explaining things to you that
you know if you stand in the rain
without an umbrella you will get wet
okay so that they're explaining
you know the functioning of the language
and if you have already acquired that
through enough listening and reading
which in the case of your native
language you have
then by and large these grammar
explanations are superfluous unless
there is a specific issue that you want
to zoom in on in which case you're
better off to google for it on your
computer now when we learn a foreign
language of course because we don't get
the same amount
of exposure that the native speaker does
therefore i think referring to the
grammar book from time to time becomes
useful but the more exposure the less
you need the grammar book except for
very specific issues
there you have it that's my take on
learning the grammar rules and i'm going
to do the same thing or more or less the
same thing see what i come up with in
french so thank you for listening
and i should point out that we're
getting as a result of my last video we
have quite a few volunteers for romanian
so over 30 languages and the many
stories where we get lots of repetition
uh these mini stories are proceeding and
as they uh
become
available i will let you know thank you
for listening bye for now
[Music]
you